[Music]
monica rogati who um has moved around a
little bit but she's like a important
data science leader and writer has like
the data science hierarchy of needs or
like the ai like hierarchy of needs like
at the bottom are things like like
logging and like collecting data and
then you like move up and like things
like at the middle or like analytics and
things like machine learning are like
way at the top like way at the top of
the of this um pyramid and
in terms of like value that people get
you you get a lot of value from
analytics from like counting things you
get a lot of value from like your first
models you train you know like simple
models linear models you know and you
it's like
you have to be pretty mature you have to
be pretty up to your hierarchy of needs
to be able to the point where you're
like i need a fancy
machine learning model that's like
learning non-linear relationships or i'm
taking advantage of
complicated math i wouldn't say i'm
motivated to work on machine learning
because it's the thing that like
offers the most value or that it's the
thing that like um
solves the most problems because i think
like the thing that solves the most
problems is like making data accessible
to people in their workplaces and that
they have the tools to be able to like
do basic analytics or train that first
model like you get the biggest wins at
that
at those lower levels i i do think the
problems like like machine learning
um
tooling is interesting because
because it is complex and people
enter into it
with different levels of experience and
um being able to build
tools to uh make that process more
streamlined is like is an interesting
challenge
[Music]
you